[Music]  yeah I want to see some they're robots  not supposed to be here we're kids man  would get away with anything I was just  a normal kid before my world fell apart  a to normal school of the normal life  some kids used to tease me Wow  who is it far as you're concerned my  boyfriend how long's that  they'd say you run like a girl family  now you're gonna take care of you I  promise  just don't expect Denny's bedtime  stories you throw like a girl  quiet like a girl  [Music]  you out of your mind you're not going  anywhere with me I wanna stay and I want  to fight them think you're badass huh is  this okay to be a kid little JLo funny  what you can do when all you have left  it pens on it done fight like a girl  yeah I felt like your girl coming with  me or what  [Music]  don't you  [Music]  oh ho busy  so now what are you getting your mom  [Music]  drop the clues of right now  [Music]  you get back in your hole think about  what you did  yes